I would do it if
wer
I'd like to go ahead and open up uh the
executive sessions for
today um and for the
audience I'd like to let you know that
we will not be
addressing these bills today and I'll
read them off we're read some of these
but the ones we will not be taking the
action on today excuse me HB 157 that's
a bill dealing with swep and a revenue
source for the swep that will be uh not
held today we are having a work session
on that particular bill with the sponsor
of the bill scheduled for Tuesday
morning at
9:15 uh that will be in the calendar and
we'll be taking action on that bill on
the Wednesday the 14th bill has to be
out of this committee by the 15 15 so
that bill will be taken up uh on on that
week coming uh the the bills uh
1583 1586 1686 and
1656 those are four bills which have
been in subcommittee which we're working
on those bills also will not be
addressed today the subcommittee has
made recommendations on the various
bills excluding the swep bill and the uh
amending language is currently being
written over in legislative services and
working with folks also in the finance
department over at doe uh we should have
that back we will be taking action on
those bills on uh
Wednesday the 14th of February and so on
the 14th of February bills which will be
discussed and acted upon are the last of
the early bills which we have they will
be 1288 due process 1305 which is not an
early bill that's freedom of speech on
college campuses 1583 the base adequacy
amount uh 1586 Foundation
budgeting 1656 which is special
education component with
inadequacy 1517 which deals with the
swep and the different Revenue Source
coming from gaming and
1686 which deals with the swept also
that is uh directing that excess money
to go back for the purpose of um funding
adequacy throughout the state so all the
all those bills will be taken up next
week so if somebody's sitting here
waiting for that you don't have to spin
your wheels any further here today
you're free to go and I see the
department Revenue Administration be
pleased to leave and um you're off the
hook uh so that being
that um the uh other areas which we're
looking at that we're looking for more
information uh the next build down which
we have uh that we'll be looking at
and this bill is uh prohibiting spending
of special education monies for any
other purpose and requiring reporting of
fund balances to the school
board um we
are looking at having a discussion but
also most likely holding that bill it's
not an early
bill
um jumping down so people know where
we're going uh 12
1265 uh penalty for failure to file
School expenditure
reports um we we we're going to have
more discussion on that as a committee
and executing um we're trying to
ascertain is that Bill H is that coming
directly from the Department of
Education or is that something that's uh
submitted by the the representive
without working with
doe um 1382 is the special education
support for military connected students
uh we're still trying to
ascertain whether the bill is
duplicative of the language that's
already in our military compact where it
says special education services and how
they'll be handle when we have a student
coming in from a DOD School somewhere
else in the country or with the military
somewhere else in the country and
they're moving uh what's the process for
addressing the IEP that they carry
forward with them uh I believe it
spelled out within the military compact
but we want to make sure if it's not
then we we will be taking up that
particular bill um next one down 1311
District collection development of uh
reconsideration policies uh we will be
discussing that today and most likely
taking action on it today
1452 Theos of superintendent of schools
and business officers uh within the
school districts we will have discussion
on that today and and uh and then uh
move forward with it uh duties and
responsibilities of SAU
superintendent uh we will be addressing
that bill today um commission to study
funding of for special education funding
that bill is a bill which is got several
components within it directions and uh
recognizing that uh catastrophic Aid
special education Aid is uh an issue
which must be addressed we see the the
benefit of that represent Heath and uh
but we want to work with you you've been
communicating with us on that so we'll
we'll have some discussion on that one
and it's not an early bill so we don't
have to make any definitive movement
today uh registration of high school
students to vote uh I understand there's
an amendment that's 10:14 I understand
there is an amendment out there we've
been working with the assistant deputy
secretary of state Aon Hennessy uh there
has been a communication we've all
received represent Damon I'm
understanding that you've so we will be
discussing that and and looking at that
and also looking at her letter to make
sure that the language parallels what is
being presented in the amendment and and
yeah
and I yeah I I that's what I've heard
from Aaron and so at any rate we will be
discussing and taking that one up today
too so those are the 1397 was on the
list but uh we've already taken action
on that and exact that it's just one of
those rollovers that got mixed in with
bills and we don't want to take action
on it
twice and so those are the Bills which
we're going to be discussing today no
other bills will come up so if you
didn't hear a bill you're interested in
you're off the
hook um so going back to the top uh with
1509 prohibiting spending of special
education funds for any other purposes
we'll open up this executive session and
discussion I I'll open this up and then
this is this is an exective session so
it's you know so that's where we are in
discussion there is concern about the
effective date of this uh April 1
2024 it says it be effective that's
uh right right upon us that date um so
uh that that's a a a concern that a
number of folks have raised and we even
I think raise addressed that briefly
during the presentation of the
bill so it's open for discussion anybody
want to oh by the way I'd like to
introduce uh representative SE and
represent Howard and representa Heath
who are standing in today for subing for
representative Howard over
representative hall Hall is for Hall
yeah right and of course you're you're
always
[Laughter]
here you've been on this committe before
as a full-time member and you're a
permanent sub with us and we appreciate
that and represent C welcome you're
thank you so we have uh 1509 any
discussion on that Bill yes represent
luno sure thank thank you very much Mr
chair and um and House Bill
adds a um adds a provision new provision
that says that essentially saying that
that this this uh special education
differentiated Aid can only be spent on
special education purposes and so I
think we got to we got to maybe take a
look at what that means in the uh in the
larger scope of um of of public school
funding and um and you know one
you know sort of finger in the wind
we've heard it from a number of places
we we've actually seen some data that
supports it that that the average cost
of special education services and this
is average and I know averages aren't
great numbers there somewhere in the
neighborhood at
$27,000 per student and the
differentiated Aid amount of special
education is more like
$2300 um per student so so that that
that amount doesn't even come close to
what the uh what the local school
district has to raise to uh to perform
uh special education services
similarly that that that amount the
$2,300 is again just an average and um
and you know and isn't isn't based on
providing specific Services it is in a
formula called adequate school funding
and so it's it's for the school district
to Pro provide an adequate education for
all of its students so I think as we if
if if we're starting to peel away these
these um um differentiated Aid factors
special
education free introduced price launch
English language learning that that
we're really we're really walking away
from Our obligation to fund an adequate
education for all students and uh it's
all part of the formula it's part of the
formula that calculates the cost of
providing an adequate education for all
of a district students not just special
education
students not just the free inter price
launch students not just the English
language Learners and and for that
reason I I I I don't think this bill
should should move forward I would
support an itl or I'd support an interim
study if um if we want to gather more
information on it in conjunct with our
our school funding information but but I
I certainly don't think the bill should
move
forward now I'm confused I've wondered
this myself a number of times in the
past why if we're giving a bump for free
and reduced lunch are we not using that
for free and reduced lunch kids why if
we're giving a bump for special educ
ation are we not using that money for
special education kids it seems like if
that's what we're giving the bump for
that's what the money should be spent
for and I don't understand how that's
not adequacy it's adequacy for those
kids because they need that extra money
so
I'm can you explain it better when we
when we appropriate money for the
opportunity for an adequate education
there's two components which go into it
the base cost right and the
differentiated Aid and the Constitution
says that we have to fund all children
equally regardless of property wealth or
property poorness within a community so
it's based on the child children your
per per
admr and so so then we allocate the it's
not Target none of the differentiate Aid
is it's listed as free and reduced or
elll or or or special education
but a superintendent does not
necessarily have to use those monies
directly they're they're non-targeted
dollars and we've had this issue when
we've dealt with the LBA many many times
in trying to develop formulas and that's
part of the reason why we always look at
the left-and side of the formula and the
right hand side of the
formula so it is you know it's it's a
difficult issue but we've tried to go
the other way around and and we've been
told we can't do it so my my concern
with this bill would be I like the
content of the intent uh however a
superintendent I'd like to right start
right down the lower level when we're
starting to build our budgets in a
school district superintendent is
building a budget off of what money St
and and off the the demographic on the
preceding year they don't know what's
coming at them in many cases in terms of
special education population for the
given year that they're planning for so
they have to Bas basically project or
estimate the best way that they can so
where do they get these additional
dollars from is money's raised locally
within your community or from that pot
that you get from the state which
oftentimes doesn't measure up to what
you really are projecting so you have to
make that difference up so what happens
at the end of that given year after
that's been approved by your legislature
in your town and there is money left in
that pot but there's another a of your
operating budget which is lower are can
they move those dollars that were
appropriated by your town which are not
State dollars necessarily from the
special education accounting form budget
and move it over here this bill would
stop that from happening so that's where
I'm in between so how how do we how do
we handle this whole thing if if they
can't it's going to have to stay over
that that pot even though they have
unfunded things on this
side chair lad
yes thank you very much for for raising
that um ra making that point chair U Mr
chairman um
that's it almost goes right to the
fundamental point of school boards too
in terms of bottom line budgeting and um
where where School boards have the
authority to um to to appro not to
appropriate but to use funds as as the
elected school board members feels
appropriate particularly as you get
towards the end of the um the school
year and and I think this bill
um is antithetical to that sort of local
control that uh that school boards
have represent Bel thank you Mr chair so
obviously being a newer member to this
committee our comp our our funding
formulas are very complicated um I've
heard number of times that places
struggle with funding for uh special
education
needs I was frankly shocked when I heard
testimony that we actually have a line
item for special education and not all
those funds are used for special
education it seems to me
unconscionable that we would actually
Rob from a fund that is specifically a
line item for special education needs
that are we know are not funded well
enough in many places and we would use
that for any other
purpose now I uh the committee is
probably familiar with the fact that I
I'm not a lover of the concept of equity
I don't like it
except except when it comes to students
with
disabilities and I think we all tend to
recognize that students with
disabilities need a little something
extra sometimes in order to participate
freely and I think that's a universal
concept we've had that since Civil
Rights Act but I I can't understand why
we would use these funds for anything
but these students especially when
they're not adequately funded as
is represent
Damon thank you Mr chair I have a couple
of
remarks I'm going to start with
acknowledging that I was here for the
entire hearing on this bill listening
intently and making many notes and I did
not hear what representative beler just
cited I did not hear that we're robbing
money from a special ed fund for other
things so I'm a little perplexed by that
I would like to also note we heard
testimony that most many specialed
students receive most of their education
in the general education setting and
that this bill is very
unclear as to if it were to
pass how we would separate out the
special education cost for students who
are included in gened it's just your Ed
educating those children in the
classroom meeting their
needs it's just not clear at all how
that would work um I very much
supporting itl on this
bill perhaps I'm Miler thank you Mr
chair I just want to Echo uh
representative Damon's comments but I
want to add too
that special education has
a certain
oversight on each School Board uh there
are a limited amount of money that is
and we've heard that time and time again
from various testimonies on various
bills about the Dilemma of of specialed
money and the lack thereof from the
state to do that we heard
testimony uh from a superintendent that
basically said look at there are reports
that go on all the time almost on a
monthly basis so the oversight for the
expenses of special ed are very clear
and this bill is not needed because of
that oversight and the preeminence of
the need to look at this on an ongoing
basis so this is not some kind this is
not some kind of a fund that gets put it
to the side or get puts to put in the
rear someplace this is up front on a
monthly basis and a school board meeting
and so I I think that that this is not
needed and uh I would it all this
motion represent cascaden thank you Mr
chair I was trying to look at line five
and six and trying to
process how to interim study if that's
the way it went um but I'm coming up
short in
practicality your special ed budgets do
have line items and are reported by line
item line item if Jane do Needs A CTV
then that's you know a piece of
equipment in that that line item um if
somebody else needs an individual Aid
that's an align item for personnel
specific to special ed and it is tracked
a school board must approve all of those
expenses every time they meet so they
call warrants and then in my experience
those warrants all went to the city and
the city had to sign off on all of those
on a monthly basis as
well um at the end of a year when you're
looking over your budget and you're
trying to work with your town or your
City on what they're going to
appropriate for the following year
you're going to look to see where you
have money left in those line items you
might have I don't know couple thousand
left in materials or something left in
personnel and now you start grouping
that whether it's from special ed or not
because a city in my case might say well
we can only give you
x amount of
dollars and since you've got Surplus
here you know we'll put that right back
into your budget where it
is um another piece is um negotiating
that Medicaid
reimbursement that becomes a revenue for
the school district in essence a revenue
for the town or the city and so it goes
in the revenue pot so again when you're
negotiating to get your school budget
funded my experience is you never get
what you want and you never get what you
request but it's negotiated they'll say
well we'll give you all the revenues
from Medicaid to put back into they
don't have to do that if they need a
plow open your schools in the
winter it may go there but it's in that
end part um the other piece your budget
in particular and special ed can change
on any given day take for example
example a family that starts a school
year has three students in your in your
District all three require special
education services then come February
and March that family packs up and moves
now you might have extra Personnel you
might have bought special materials for
any one of the children or provided
services so now those dollars aren't
necessarily expended so you get a
balance in those areas you may have a
student all of a sudden whose Foster
family moves to the city which has
happened and the city is now responsible
to pay the education of that student
wherever they are in my case they were
in
Dairy um so it's that fluid on Special
Ed but at the end of the
day most of those dollars all stay in
special end because if there's something
that you've been wanting to purchase for
the need of something and you have extra
money you have that flexibility to do
that what I'm worried about is this bill
would prevent you from being able to use
your dollars where they are best served
towards kids so I I I don't need it Echo
that and I'd say itl when I was putting
budgets together and if I did have a
balance left in an account like that but
I also looked over here and said our
fuel tanks and the buildings are
empty and the the price of fuel now is a
great buy and if I wait it's going to
spike why not put that money over here
to save the taxpayer dollars later and
that's what I did and so it it's and and
the balance often times was a result of
just what you said you're projecting but
the projection is maybe projected higher
because somebody left or or any
circumstance variable so those are some
things which have to be considered that
local have to be left with that decision
making ability yeah represent dry thank
you and maybe representative cascad or
you could answer where to federal funds
targeted I don't think
they're Ida funds stay in idea because
those are through the grants management
system that they're they're not the type
that are raised through your community
which appropriated locally they're
different and you have to use them
accordingly in accordance with federal
ed and other discussion represent Tanner
aren't the federal aren't the federal
funds generally overseen by the
Department of Education that they're the
ones that kind of keep track of well
there it's reporting back yes yes it's
grant money yes
discussion okay um
know we're we're we'll have a caucus
before we take action here before we
recognize any
motion uh but there will probably be a
need for several caucuses today so let's
jump to another bill then we can come
back to this bill because we do not have
a motion on the
floor representa cordelli have you been
able to make any contact with the um
military compact people um I have not
sign I can go call them right now or
whenever it's yeah whenever it's
convenient let's let's keep moving
here
um penalty for failure to file School
um
1265 let's let's open that up for a
discussion right now
okay without I'm going to run upstairs
and pick up some amendments is there
anything I can get for anybody upstairs
uh unless there's something in a
fold yeah yeah something to drink yeah
uhuh anybody any amendments from
okay
Bill what were you had what you had for
that
one
okay they how
everybody want make motion well no how
are they on that
okay is there anybody wants to discuss
this before we take a motion on the
floor
bill
was this for anybody in the committee
was this a request of
doe you think it
was did he make any reference to the to
the second section there which is the
new
paragraph 14 lines 14 through
21 um if I might I believe um it was
mentioned that this was um left out of
uh hb2 it was originally supposed to be
out
okay and the other changes are they
Academy do you remember
why
so my notes
say
um the publicy don't set
OTP okay uh represent leus do you want
that move
OTP is there a
second I'll second okay we have motion
OTP on
1265 made by represent leus and second
by representa cordelli further
discussion represent leus to care to
speak to your motion just that this was
requested by
sense
okay okay is there any further
bill no further discussion on the
bill okay uh Madam clerk will you please
call the roll in 1265 Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative laus yes
repres representative
C yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative panel yes representative
Corell yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell
yes representative Tanner no
representative
Luna oh
is he went to get the copies
copies
go ahead and jump to the other people
but we won't I won't put the gavel down
till he gets back representative Heath
no representative Woodcock no
Bon
yes representative
Damon
no uh chairman lad
yes and and back to representative
Lun here represent represent we're in a
um a vote to look at uh 1265 the motion
is
OTP no
no okay so the total vote is 13 yay 7
passes
bill
1382 did you get through you didn't okay
we'll jump over 1382 then uh
agreement we already B on 155 yeah yeah
so we'll go to 1552 uh HB
next represent
I look to you for a motion uh thank you
Mr chairman uh I would move on to pass
is there a
second second represent mil makes a
second on that so we have a motion OTP
on 552 this is relative the duties and
responsibilities of superintendent of
school administrative units made by
represent cordelli and second by
represent Miler further
discussion yes um very simply um in
statute now um
it says that um you can have a
superintendent but it's not required to
have a superintendent as long as there
is someone assigned to perform
superintendent Services which are
defined in statute um in several many
places throughout though um given our
education statutes um it says the the
superintendent
shall Etc so this clarifies in all those
places um that this superintendent shall
or Personnel assigned to perform
superintendent Services Under RSA 194 C5
Etc so it's a clarification about um the
statute further discussion yes represent
Woodcock thank you chairman L I have
reservations about the bill because it
looks to me like it is is strictly
administrated way to reduce costs and
has nothing to talk about improving the
education of the youngsters in the
district or the efficiency see the
administrative office um so I from that
bill representative kiscaden thank you
26 does that mean that you could assign
a principal to be the superintendent and
Licensing would not come into play here
or am
I does it mean like you can assign
anybody to take over if you don't have a
superintendent in the district um I
believe that U I wasn't sure anyone can
be assigned any sorry yeah thank you uh
anyone can be assigned um to perform the
superintendent Services it could be
steep uh is
there Barett do you have any
clarification on that that so we can get
beyond what I
believe because I I I was always under
the impression that in a single School
District that's usually your small
responsibilities thank you thank you
chairman L good morning members of the
committee as I testified during um
during the hearing on the bill um there
is for smaller districts there's a a
specific certification from the
Department called a district
administrator certain criteria no I
think it's only one building and fewer
than a certain number certain number of
students it's almost I called it
principle plus that individual serves as
a principal but is um authorized through
that certification to sign certain
documents I presume both for the state
and feds if need be um representative
cordelli to your to your comment a
second ago about the assignment of
superintendent services to perhaps a
principal or a a business manager our
understand understanding is that the
individual that is assigned um to
perform those superintendent Services
would still have to have superintendent
certification the provision in RSA 194c
I forget what sub paragraph it is um
four maybe or five where it talks about
um assigning the services um the only
situation there may be more but the only
one that I'm aware of in New Hampshire
where a district does not have a quote
unquote superintendent in place um
is uh the Middleton School District
essenti actually there's two now that I
can think of the middlet the Middleton
School Board purchases its services from
the governor Wentworth School District
um so governor with the superintendent
and Governor Wentworth through a
contract with middle with Middleton
performs their Middleton superintendent
Services whether or not that's all the
central office services I don't know I'm
also aware that Rollinsford purchases
its superintendent services from uh
summersworth uh there may be more but
those are the two that I'm aware of so
you either need again our understanding
is that the individual we need to have
uh certification from the Department as
a superintendent or in the circumstances
I talked about that District
administrator position where I think
there's only one in the state that is
doing that now and there were a couple
other that have have tinkered with it
over the last 10 or 15
years represent um I believe that the
town
Monroe um had a part-time superintendent
for years and then the acting principal
um then assumed that role but she had to
um become certified as a superintendent
so I believe she's dual certified it's
it's possible yeah I know Monroe went
with the district administrator model
for a while I know lime did it for a
while um and um Mason is the one that
has done it pretty successfully for I
want to say the last maybe close to
moving on 15 years would be my
guess that's a small district and they
went back to an uh got a superintendent
been retired in brought out of
retirement where was where was that sir
mon in Monroe yeah yeah but I believe I
mean my experience as an interim is that
a district is purchasing the services of
a licensed superintendent and that's why
you see a lot of
interim retirees that do these jobs
right because they but for the purposes
of not having a quote unquote B
in the central office if you will
they're they're providing they're
purchasing the service Middleton is its
own SAU purchases services from the
governor wler School District SE 49 I
believe it is um Rollinsford is its own
School District it's their their own sa
they purchase their central office
services from
summersworth so is this by way of
Statute or by uh Ed education rule well
the certification is obviously rules the
the the purchasing of services is in
194c I'm 34 something something
on superintendent Services I was
concerned more with the certification
aspect it was reing the BB
certified I see all the services there
I've looked them there's a Litany of
them right down through a through R
correct it says
um anyway you're providing the services
the district has to provide the services
you can do that either by having your
own superintendent or Again by hiring
paying to have a a superintendent in a
neighboring District provide them for
you okay representative
Balon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um can you
explain a little bit further what is
that uh District Administrative um
position that uh people can qualify that
can take the place of a superintendent
and what does that entail in terms of uh
extra work or sure thank you very much
representative um so the district
administrator that is a a title of a job
position that is a certified position
under Department of Education roles I
presume it's in the 500s
somewhere um it it the person if you
have a district administrator
certification generally in the
circumstances the two or three districts
that have tinkered with that model over
the years that individual that holds
that certification is serving as a
principal of a small school their
day-to-day job is primarily being the
principal of that school however that
District ad administrator certification
authorizes that individual to sign off
on on documents that would be required
by the Department of Education the feds
um that would normally be required to be
signed by the superintendent I think
that's really the only distinction is
that it's a principal certification
a little bit more of coursework if you
will for but not as much as a
superintendent um but the individuals
are serving as a principal you know from
7:30 to 5:00 but then they're authorized
to sign whatever documents would need to
be signed the warrant the Dr stuff the
idea stuff the federal stuff all that
kind of stuff but the so I hope that
answers your question and and there are
limitations on on districts that can't
have a district administrator it has to
be a small District there's a cap on the
number of students and a cap on the
number of buildings within that District
in order to have a district
administrator serving that
role Bon um can um somebody who wants to
apply to be a district administrator is
there like a a temporary where you can
say you're going to do it and work
towards it and still have the role yeah
thank you for the thank you for the
question I I I don't know if I don't
know the certification rules is but
maybe as well as I should just I'm not
an educator so I don't I'm not exactly
sure how that how that works through the
department further
discussion thank you very represent he
thank you Mr chair thank you we are for
taking my question um the role of the
superintendent um is pretty extensive um
and with that role they carry all the
liability I mean the buck stops with the
superintendent so in this case where's
the buck going to stop in I'm sorry in
what case representative the in the
situation of of this bill I I don't I I
remember the bill I don't have a copy of
I thank
you thank you
so will will this position carry the the
liability for that District I
mean
I think in in and and reading through
the bill again in relative to the the
measures I think as I'm reading the bill
and not speaking to your intent
representative cordelli I'm reading the
bill as for the fire for the fire safety
then well Personnel assigned I
mean
superintendent I'm sorry I'm a little
I'm trying to piece together a couple
each and may
assign okay so reading the current law
you don't have to have and you may
assign these services to one more sort
of personnel working for
part-time or such Services maybe
independently contract raed I'm not
aware of any districts that have the one
or more administrative Personnel working
for part-time the services well or if
they
are I could probably use some help from
an administrator maybe um
um you know so so what I if we look at
the superintendent services in RSA 194
C4 paragraph 2 that a through R the
superintendent is ultimately responsible
for the but those are certainly
delegated to a special education
director a business manager a principal
so on and so forth so you know Jerry I
don't know if you want to speak to sort
of the assigning the duties and how it
may are they delegated by the school
board I mean generally no I mean we we
tend to advise that the superintendent
works for the board but all other
employees work for the superintendent
because the superintendent is respons
responsible in 194 C4 paragraph 2 for
the um uh oversight and evaluation and
supervision of all employees with the
district and we're talking a very small
District yeah I mean well small or large
the super inent is ultimately
responsible for all the employees within
within the
district we could be talking about a
district like landf that has 40 kids
right right and I mean I'm looking at
the you know I I'm looking at the 194
C5 superintendent shall not be required
and may assign I I I think you know I
think I think representative cordell's
sort of interpretation or take on that
provision in in C5 2A that the
superintendent May assign is not
required to have a superintendent and
may assign these services to one or more
administrative personnel and so if
you're assigning this the services to a
special ed
director I don't know who's in charge
like who's signing off on the pertinent
documents that are required under both
state and federal law looking to the
looking to some of the administrators
and well thank you Mr let's hear Jerry
first and then uh Jerry F associate
executive director of New Hampshire
school administrators Association first
and foremost I am not a lawyer I have no
legal training and other than what I
needed to achieve my degree so I don't
know the legal compon onon of and can
site as brilliantly as Barett can
chapter and law of of what things are
talking about
um but ultimately in in each district um
and i' I've as Barrett's been talking
I've been running through my head who
our current folks are and I'm not aware
of any District uh that has anyone who
is not certified as a superintendent
serving that purpose you may recall
yesterday I alluded to the small
District of Hill
and Brian Conley who is serving in many
capacities but he holds a ticket as a as
a
superintendant um uh and I believe the
district administrator that who who BR
Barrett refers to also holds
certification as a superintendent so um
and the part-time many of the part-time
positions that are filled uh by folks
are typically filled by retired
superintendant uh that don't serve in
the
legislature um but many of
those um many but all of those part-time
folks hold a credential as a
superintendent and in another piece of
legislation that you'll uh contemplate
today uh offers some flexibility if you
will in Pathways toward uh
superintendent
certification um we've mused a bit about
the duties and responsibilities of the
superintendent because the i i i digress
to share a funny story with you funny in
some ways uh we had a superintendent
show up at a meeting earlier this year
who the day before had dawned his pit
boots with a chainsaw uh because his
facility manager was ill and couldn't
perform the function of destroying the
Beaver Dam that was about to flood
school property and so the
superintendent said well we can't have
that happen and there's no contractor to
do it so on with the waiters and in to
the swamp and business with a chainsaw
that's nowhere in you know a through z
even not other duties as aign because
nobody ass signed that so there's there
are different things that that folks do
and it has no that particular uh
instance has nothing to do with
certification but is just an example of
what what's bothering me where the
stops we're talking about small
districts here and and
that instructional leader that principal
instructional leader probably knows the
town a whole lot
better than the contracted servic is
sitting 50 mil away or 20 miles away and
has a ticket and um we're looking at
instructional decisions and
administrative
decisions many
principles have it's just like you can
have a CES a certificate Advanced study
or have a PhD as a superintendent but
many of these principles have the
finances that's been part of their
master's program uh they certainly have
you
know awareness of where the statutes are
they can read a book just like a
superintendent can you just as said
you're you're not an attorney either um
so so why is this
not what is wrong with this bill where
we're trying to get this instructional
leader in a small District to make these
decisions other than some regulation
saying we have to have certification to
do that thank you then I don't know if
you're asking either one of us but I I
just in looking through the statutes
again in C5 and then readings line 10
and
11 and then reading lines 15 and 16 it's
at least consistent right the the the
the provisions in lines 10 and 11 and 15
and 16 are consistent with the language
in in C5
A2 um the the the as I testified I don't
I don't think we took a position on this
bill I I may be mistaken on that the the
provisions at the end in lines 23
through
27 the the the principal instructional
leader again that's not that position is
not a certified position under depart
current Department of Education roles
the district administrator is what I
believe this is is trying to get at so
there's an incon there's consistency in
language on 10 and 11 with C 194 C5
consistency in lines 15 and 16 with
current Statute in 194
C5 we think there's an inconsistency in
203 through 27 with what the current
Department of Education roles
are represent
cordelli yeah um as I said
the intent was very
simple we talked about C5 uh 2A School
District shall not be required to have a
superintendent May assign those Services
that's what I tried to reflect because
there are places 20 some odd places in
statute where it says the superintendent
shall and I thought for consistency
purposes we should
reflect you know for a change maybe um
you know what is inste statute elsewhere
in our education statutes um the bottom
of the um Bill related to 23 through 26
as you mentioned um was given to me um
[Music]
department Steve gave you that right
yeah yeah yes represent
Tanner um I I see that the the bottom
number number four um is for single
District school administrative units um
but the other ones just say
superintendent of schools for school
districts uh so it really isn't just all
small schools it's it's any district and
I'm just
wondering um My worry is that this isn't
because there's been so much focus on
Administration and how it really eats up
money and doesn't add to the education
of kids and yada yada yada that this
bill would be a vehicle for getting rid
superintendent when I drafted this my
intent was not to partner this with any
other
legislation dealing with superintendent
or getting rid of any staff I was trying
to provide some consistency in our
statutes for a change
yeah represent about Cas
Caden um in looking in the Bureau of
certification they require a lot of the
same requirements as a superintendent in
terms of a district administrator okay
so they need at least a Masters or a
higher ed they have to be certifiable as
a superintendent pretty much but I sort
of equate the language in 24 and
25 that your dental hygienist is not
going to do your root canal or nurse is
not going to perform your heart
surgery and somebody has to maintain the
high that puts that's a little
concerning may I may I comment real
quickly on one more thing representative
Cordell you said that you got the the
principal instructional leader language
from from the Department I believe in
one of the drafts of the minimum
standards the 306s I believe that was a
consideration at one at one point they
were going to put a provision in there
about principal instructional leader I
think they were defining that again
that's gone through a thousand
different
variations um I know Mr bermonte sent me
a a draft I think it was label number
two earlier this week I haven't looked
at it so I don't know if that's still in
there so that could have been the
commissioner working on some of the
rules as well too so that that may be
where that came from as well to
representative so ref San
Luna thank you very much Mr chair so so
question to both the um you know uh to
Barrett with school boards admin um
School Board Association and to and to
Jerry with the school administrators
Association um looking at the looking at
the bill listening to what the prime
sponsor has said that that the the the
the two sections at the top are really
to sort of clarify that that you know
where there's a superintendent or a
person that's been assigned the role of
superintendent um uh can be provided uh
certain information
um and then the and then the last
section with with that that now we're
we're sort of showing a a route for
somebody who's a building principal to
take on the role of su responsibilities
of superintendent in a small District I
guess my question to both of you is is
this really needed um you know when
we've got either somebody that's hired
as a superintendent or hired to perform
the role of the
superintendent um and and obviously both
of you are very interested in making
sure that school districts have access
to
to high you know U superintendent
qualified Personnel to lead districts
that are held to high standards um are
we having you know is is this bill
really
needed
first thank you for the question
representative luno um I would say that
we have successfully filled a positions
of systems leadership uh we continue to
do so through highly qualified
candidates I think we
need Pathways toward the superintendency
that another piece of legislation
addresses uh it's absolutely important
that we have um the most qualified
people in these systems leadership's
position and I'm going to take it a step
further and
say if you're a principal in a small
district and you have the additional
responsibilities of the superintendent
duties of
responsibilities principal in a small
district has a
pretty uh demanding position uh they do
everything uh they might not necessarily
have a curriculum coordinator they might
not necessarily have
uh uh an IT director they might not you
know I I've talked about other examples
where principles in small District they
work pretty hard as it is trying to meet
the needs of their staff their kids
their families and the community at
large and so to to expect even that a
principal can successfully uh execute
all the duties of uh where the buck
stops if you will in addition to the
Daily responsibilities of monitoring the
lunchroom uh is a is a big stretch and
so I think that uh it's um you know
we've
managed our state has managed to fill
those positions and so I would suggest
that um we have a system in place that's
working with a little more flexibility
Pell so I was looking at this and yes we
all we look at um RSA
194c no
yes 194 C5 Roman numeral 2A which says
we don't have to have a superintendent
and I think the problem here is that if
you look at don't read the bolded
line just read the the sentence without
it it talks about a superintendent shall
or this shall be done by a
superintendent and the problem
is if we don't put that bolded part in
to take care of the fact for those
instances when we don't have a
superintendent if we don't pat that in
the law is saying that a superintendent
shall be doing this but we don't have a
superintendent so I think all this is
supposed to be doing is by putting that
bolded line in there is just to say or
if we don't have a superintendent this
person because otherwise you have the
superintendent shall or this shall be
done by the superintendent we don't have
one thank you thank you for I guess a
statement semi- there representative I
what what I would say to that is that
there is an inherent authority of a
superintendent to De to delegate the
statute doesn't need to be specific if
it says a superintendent shall you know
for example we talked about the services
in RSA 190 for 194 4
C4 um you know the each school
administrative unit or single School
shall F provide the following
superintendent
Services payroll cash flow bills records
and files the superintendent isn't the
one doing the payroll it's delegated to
to other staff so I think that there's
just there's a natural and inherent
authority of a superintendent to
delegate as as needed and I don't mean
to be rude if it's okay if Becky came up
and took my spot I have to get to
another bill at 11:00
if that would that be all right by you
Mr chair sure thank you
perhap Mr chair uh before we vote on
this particular Bill and call for the
vote would it be possible for us to also
look at
1452 which also talks about
superintendencies and kind of pull both
those two bills together so that we can
have kind of a full look at what the
superintendent supposed to do and uh its
responsibilities I mean is that possible
to do um the
superintendent don't it's not it's not
early b not nor is that um but I I have
real concerns here and I can reflect on
my days
when don't I was this person this piece
here
and the principal in the building which
I was when I first started out
in West Peru Maine I handled all of it
all of it the superintendent was
somewhere up in the Rumford area and
never saw us and and I did all that
reporting because my master's program
had taught me all that and when I left
then the district immediately the town
of West Brew decided we are going to not
have superintendent Services we're going
to have it through the person we have
employed as principal SLS superintendent
and we're going to take that credential
that the the master's program which was
coming out of gorm and it it worked and
I can also recall when I was this young
officer in Vietnam and there every
battery out in the field had a captain
well the captain was worthless the one
that was running the show was the
executive officer here was a lonely
second Lieutenant than first lieutenant
and I was able to run that battery
better than that Captain was and so you
can delegate but it's what's above the
shoulders which gets the job done and I
think if you have a proper person the
prop in the place you can get it done
and the credentials I yeah I respect
superintendent and I understand what
they've gone through they've just paid a
few more bucks for their degree um I I
trying to put you down over there but I
I I really truly believe that these
people can do their job and in a small
District you're talking about you're
going to have to have this contracted
service and it's an additional cost for
a small community can afford
it can we call Caucus please pardon me
can we call Caucus not just yet no um we
will but you know we're not going to
take action on this so at any rate uh
we're going to get all the people have
their hands up first for the discussion
represent whitcock thank you chair um
I'm listening you talk almost like we
don't need any administrat just hire the
people can do the job we don't need
license you uh I'm must Su Jus you
didn't do a hell of a job I'm saying and
my my concern my concern is in lines 24
25 26 as they were when we took the bill
up you know I was going to ask Barett
but I'm sure Mr Po answer the question
currently in doe regulations and maybe M
wil could help us because we don't have
a doe rep uh attorney here right to help
us for doe I I don't see anybody from do
okay so we have to use other services so
the PRP the principal the principal
instructional leader is that a is that a
may I ask is that a a category is that
is that a
certification thank you for the question
in listening to what representative lad
was just referencing a principal who
also would act in the capacity of having
some of these superintendent Services
under their
jurisdiction it's my interpretation and
Jerry may feel differently or not but
that that person would qualify to become
certified as a district administrator
that is the certification the
qualifications it's
506.com is the administrator of a school
district or an SAU with 400 or fewer
total school age enrollments no more
than two Public Schools as defined in
306 and then it enters out in terms of
you have to be a certified principal you
have to meet the qualifications Etc so
that person would fall under that
certification
probably my point my question M Wilson
is um is the title as referred to in
this bill
that someone may be certified for
principal instructional leader there I'm
looking right now I I I didn't find it
so I don't I don't believe that that is
a certification title okay so the bill
refers to and may certified as a
principal stru leader we don't have that
position the other question and I I have
a difficulty with in line 25 this not
end with you just you just had to be
stuck there um is the fact we don't have
definition of rigorous process it talks
about we first of we don't have we don't
have the position it's not there there's
no certification for that position and
we're making it up and then we say we
have a Rous progress process for
selection but we don't have what that is
either we don't have a definition what
rigorous process is so I I I don't get
it so um I understand small schools one
gu doing or woman doing a heck of a job
and it happens all over oh we're we're
not debating with the folks here are
Pleasant enough to come up and help us
out we're debating amongst a club right
here well thank you um since I could
thank you but that was my point both of
you represent Damon did you have your
hand up
first thank you Mr chair representative
Woodcock said most of what I was going
to say so I will just concur thank you
you're welc but also in the prior
hearing on this and I'm looking at uh
line
1819 it was noted that single District
school administrative units are not
necessarily small Manchester and nashaa
fall in that category so we need to be
careful in looking at this that we're
not only speaking of it for these little
rural districts there's more in here um
I I find this uh the language in
the second half of the bill to be vague
and very concerning if we had like a a
small district with 100 or fewer
students would that make a
difference
well
represent leus so I have
a procedural question as far as how
these things come to be so we currently
don't have a principal instructional
leader but if we wanted one isn't this
how we create it through law we create a
position I'm not sure but that was what
I thought is that we create the position
and this describes the position
it's done through the Department of
Education is that how it's done that's
why I wondered thank you
yes Jerry Thank you Mr chairman I I just
want to restate we have a vehicle for
that exactly what uh representative like
I say alluded to is the district
administrator that could be the
superintendent s the principal plus as
as Barrett um alluded to we have that
certification that's already available
for districts who choose that
group yeah is there any more discussion
amongst the committee representative
Heath just want to make a a a comment
about um your you talking about your
role as an administrator in your school
district um I think in
fact you carried out a role But
ultimately the superintendent was
overseeing you somehow some way and he
or she would be responsible my concern
concern with this bill is I don't see
who ultimately and I haven't gotten my
answer yet about who carries the
liability who's making sure everybody's
doing the job that they've been
designated to do who who where does a
buck stop who's
responsible would it be the uh as we say
on line 24 there the alternative
certification as principal's
instructional leader would that person
be the one where the buck stops who
would it be the school
board
well the the somebody's going to have to
recommend the hiring or firing of an
instructor or a teacher and that's to
the school board the principal doesn't
do it right now you recommend to your
superintendent the superintendent has to
take that forward this right here would
say that this person in that if it were
a small District that's what I've always
assumed this is is for the single when I
talk single School District I'm not
talking Manchester
but maybe that needs need some
definition here um I was thinking that
this person be the one that has those
authorities what you're talking so that
person is respon if I may so that person
is responsible directly to the school
board yes and with that carries the
responsibility to oversee and make sure
all things are happening the way they
should be and if in fact something goes
aai is the person that bears the burden
of the penalty for that yes thank you
yes that that would be the person with
those superintendent responsibilities
would be this they may not have the
superintendent ticket but they may have
the experience to training the Masters
that covers that in a small District a
very very small
District
yes thanks very much
um just following on that line the the
the comments made just now um I just
want to um mention that I passed around
uh
the amendment which replaces the bill on
House Bill 1452 which which Jerry FW was
I think referring to earlier that
addresses credentials for um
superintendent and school business
officers but um uh but my you know I
think my point being that that what what
you're talking about Mr chair with
respect to some of these positions
whether they're they're
um um principal administrators that can
that can that can lead a district those
All Fall Down fall into the um the the
Ed rules for certification for these
rules is that
correct yeah that they have to go
through Ed rules yes right right and and
that that possibly what we're what we're
talking about here in the bill that's
before us now and in the the the next
bill
1452 with respect to the qualifications
for or um or for certification for these
roles they could be looked at together
and um and you know and maybe worked on
together uh as
well or they could be worked on as your
separately in each each bill that that's
what I'm saying yeah yes yes but but
recognizing that that that they're both
um interrelated yeah okay thank you
yeah represent
leus so my question
comes if a school district as it says
doesn't have to have a
superintendent and we're talking about
well these people that would be assigned
by the superintendent how can we have a
person assigned by a superintendent if a
school district doesn't have one which
the law says they don't have to and so
question because when I asked before who
would do whatever the answer was well
the person assigned by the
what that that's not what I was saying
at all no I didn't this person would
have those responsibilities that the
superintend I was going back yeah okay I
was going back to previous discussion
and that it says the superintendent
usually you know chooses is somebody to
do these the requirements right like the
payroll a superintendent would assign
somebody to do payroll well if there is
no
superintendent which the law says there
doesn't have to be who makes that
assignment superintendent can delegate
all they want to if there's no
superintendent how does it get delegated
that's my question well we're talking
about putting it as responsibility
within the definition certification for
this particular La the way it is now
that's why this is here I believe well
that was what I was trying to yeah
represent superintendent that also
happened in l i November um and in both
instances the school board chair who was
signing off on those absolutely
necessary
obviously could do a lot of the work
like you say
pay but it was a school board chair that
was going in to sign
off out stressing out over it they
didn't want the liability but they were
the ones that
assumed that charge so there a
vacancy now the SCH board
chair
out okay so I I don't think we're going
to get much farther thank you very much
uh on on this I think we do need to have
some discussion in our individual
caucuses and and maybe uh further
discussion on the bill but I don't want
to take all day doing
it um which we're running down that
path would we be voting for a principal
instructional
leader who certification when there is
no such thing there is no alternative
certification right and right
now right and it's when I read that it
mean if be that we'd be telling doe that
we want this
certification developed to allow what I
think the intent is so be voting for it
before it was
yes sorry Mr chair and members of the
committee for intruding one more time um
I I would submit that with principal
instructional leader not being a
recognized
certification that would that position
fall under the code of conduct and
ethics we've had that introduced in
other areas the district administrator
because it's a certified a state
recognized certified position would fall
under the code of conduct and code of
ethics principal instructional leader
isn't a recognized term so I just raised
the question would that fall under the
code of
ethics and the code of conduct because
it's not specific I don't know the
answer to that again it's just a
question that popped into mind thank you
yes I know that quelli um intent spoken
intent was for small school district you
and you discuss small school districts
as applicable to this bill but um
someone over here brought the case could
be so I look at it uh through my
assistant here helping me very much 1941
and just on the definition of the single
district school district is it possible
that a
Manchester a
conquer could be applicable under this
law under this bill change could it
falls under the definition 1941 of a
single School District I know it's not
the attempt but if I want to play that
game is that possible well the statute
have to be changed or there have to be
added addition to the statute amended to
identify whatever the small define
configuration was 100 or less but today
as it is it could have been a conquer of
Manchester I I get that I understand
that you don't have to convince me on
that yeah do you want to caucus on this
thing so we're gonna we're going to
caucus at this time on on this bill and
while we're doing it we also look at
1452 in your
caucuses do I have time to
yes you
okay we're looking at both
those yeah we're primarily looking at
this one and then we will but you might
might might be is there if there is any
I don't know if there is or not I don't
is
just
we're back into session right now and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to uh
recess everything that we're doing right
now and not take any further action on
any bills today and so we will close uh
adjourn um the bills which we have been
discussing um the the one bill which we
have acted upon um I am going to try to
get um uh clarification from the clerk's
office whether we can count that vote
minus for example represent luno who was
out and of and and I had thought when he
went out he checked out with me when he
came back in you know uh I should not
have allowed him to come in and
participate in that vote his vote didn't
make any difference so it's it's on how
this meeting was conducted and so
chances are I'd like to go through that
bill again and do it properly and and
only have those that are voting that are
actually seated here uh at the table uh
taking action on so another bad vote on
that yeah take them both so so at any
rate at this point in time the uh the
meeting meetings are journ or our close
you any we're not on anymore
okay because I just saying that my vote
that